hey guys my name is just McDonald it is
the 13th of October you're watching
gamespot news and there's a 10 out of 10
game review on games but again I'm not
gonna talk about that but check it out
so gran turismo 7 is coming to ps4 in
twenty fifteen or twenty sixteen so
sometime in the future maybe a safe way
of freezing it the next iteration of
driving franchise was originally set to
land late this year on ps4 according to
series creator Kazunori Yamauchi while
this is a significant change in launch
window yamauchi did spend some time
talking about his fondness for
developing on the ps4 explaining ps3 was
much much more difficult the high
quality of data that we have being
rendered on the ps4 I think is going to
make an incredible difference he also
said the plan is to do everything in
Gran Torino seven that they couldn't do
in sick picking a PlayStation 4 racing
games if you're one of the people unable
to connect to the drive club servers you
could be in for some kind of
compensation evolution studios have said
they really didn't expect the server
struggles they've faced and promised
that they did performance testing prior
to launch apparently all the words in
the world aren't soothing the wounds of
gamers who just want to play the damn
thing though so game director Paul rust
Shinsky said the plan to offer gamers
some form of compensation hasn't been
ruled out we're not sure what form this
compensation might come in as yes but
possibilities might include free DLC all
the joy of seeing the epically enjoyable
name brzezinski enough times until you
forget that that game you paid for
doesn't work finally Ubisoft Montreal's
Rainbow six siege will be 60 frames per
second on xbox one ps4 and PC there's no
word on the resolution just yet but we
will get that all-important frame rate
that Ubisoft has said previously matters
so much in shooters and not so much in
Assassin's Creed as we heard last week
Rainbow six siege still isn't due out
for several months so we're likely to
hear more down to try
stage of ubisoft's counter-strike like
team-based multiplayer game that was out
of the ashes of the cancelled rainbow 6
patriots and was announced at e3 this
year ask you a question of the day let
me know in the comments down below if
you think a high frame rate is important
for shooters or equally important for
games of any genre if you're after more
newsy bits and pieces we've got stories
on virtual reality being great for
horror and dice fixing battlefield 4
that is it for me today thanks for
tuning in and i'll be back same time and
place tomorrow so i hope to see you then